Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec.
J'ai pris le train au début du mois pour aller au CHR de la Citadelle à Liège, où j'ai rencontré Michelle Nisolle, qui est gynécologue, chirurgienne et professeure à l'Université de Liège.
C'était avant que la deuxième vague soit officiellement prononcée. Je marchais tranquillement dans les rues de Liège et je voyais encore des gens sans masque.
Je suis rentré dans l'hôpital sans aucun problème.
Je pense que les choses ont pas mal changé entretemps. Depuis le début de cette saison de Septante Minutes Avec, j'ai passé du temps avec des gens plutôt médiatisés, plutôt connus du grand public comme François Gemenne ou Rokhaya Diallo.
Mais à côté de ça, j'aime bien aussi donner de la visibilité à des gens, des professeurs, des chercheurs, des médecins qui bossent dans leur coin et qui ont potentiellement beaucoup de choses à nous apprendre.
Et aujourd'hui, comme promis, le sujet, c'est l'endométriose, une maladie qui concerne plus d'une femme sur dix et qui reste assez peu connue.
C'est déjà le quarante-et-unième épisode de ce podcast. Au total, j'ai interviewé vingt-et-une femmes. En toute logique, il est assez probable que plusieurs d'entre elles soient concernées par l'endométriose.
Peut-être deux ou trois selon les statistiques qu'on a. Et comme on va le voir dans cet épisode, il est tout à fait possible qu'elles ne soient pas du tout au courant de leur maladie.
Du coup, c'est un peu dans une démarche de service public que je vous propose aujourd'hui cet entretien avec le docteur Michelle Nisolle.
C'est parti. J'ai le plaisir d'être aujourd'hui avec Michelle Nisolle. Michelle Nisolle, bonjour.
Bonjour monsieur.
Vous êtes professeure à l'Université de Liège et cheffe de service en gynécologie au CHR de la Citadelle.
Exactement.
On est réunis aujourd'hui pour parler, pour explorer ensemble le sujet de l'endométriose, sujet qui n'est pas très connu, je dirais, de manière générale du grand public, alors que ça affecte de nombreuses personnes, de nombreuses femmes.
Avant de se plonger au cœur du sujet, j'aimerais vous poser quelques questions sur vous. Qu'est-ce qui vous a amenée, vous-même, à vous pencher sur la question de l'endométriose ?
Donc je m'intéresse à ce sujet de l'endométriose depuis, je dirais, 1986, 87.
D'accord.
Donc j'ai eu la chance de faire ma formation en tant que gynécologue obstétricienne à l'Université catholique de Louvain et cette université était très très fortement intéressée par le sujet.
Donc directement dès ma formation en gynécologie, j'ai été amenée à traiter des patientes et cela m'a amenée, quelques années plus tard, à défendre ma thèse de doctorat sur l'endométriose.
Donc historiquement, 1987, à ce stade, on en est où à l'échelle de la médecine dans le monde vis-à-vis de l'endométriose ?
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose de complètement inconnu ? Est-ce que vous débarquez comme une exploratrice ? Où est-ce qu'on en est à ce stade ?
Non, pas tout à fait. Je ne pense pas que l'on puisse se vanter. Je ne suis pas une pionnière dans la découverte de l'endométriose puisqu'elle a déjà été décrite dans les années 1800, donc fin du XIXe siècle.
Et déjà dans les années 1900, début 1900, y avait déjà des théories que l'on étudie encore actuellement, aujourd'hui. Donc le sujet était connu, mais pas très répandu en Belgique, certainement, et à travers le monde.
Donc les patientes n'étaient pas bien dépistées et bien traitées, je dirais, à l'époque.
D'accord. Entre 1987 et aujourd'hui, il s'est écoulé une petite trentaine, une, oui, une bonne trentaine d'années déjà.
Quelles évolutions est-ce que vous avez pu observer ? Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, vous diriez que c'est quelque chose de beaucoup mieux détecté, que les choses ont évolué vers le positif ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'il reste encore du chemin à parcourir ?
Je dirais que dans les questions que vous me posez, les réponses y sont. Donc je pense que nous avons déjà bien avancé dans la détection.
On en reparlera tout à l'heure, j'espère. Mais je dirais le problème qui reste encore entier, c'est vraiment : pourquoi une patiente développe de l'endométriose et pourquoi une autre n'en développe pas ?
Je dirais même si sur trente ans, nous avons fait beaucoup de travaux, à l'heure actuelle, on n'a pas de réponse à la physiopathogenèse, donc au développement de l'endométriose en tant que telle.
Alors tout ça nous amène à la question la plus évidente : qu'est-ce que c'est en fait l'endométriose ?
La définition de l'endométriose, c'est la présence d'endomètre. Donc l'endomètre, c'est le tissu qui tapisse la cavité utérine, qui va se disposer dans des situations ectopiques, c'est-à-dire dans la cavité pelvienne,
sur les reins, parfois dans les poumons.
Donc ce sont des localisations en dehors de l'utérus, d'un tissu qui normalement doit se trouver dans la cavité utérine.
Oui, et donc ce tissu qui se nomme l'endomètre.
Exact.
Alors déjà là, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un petit peu des guerres de définition puisque certains médecins, certaines gynécologues affirment que ce tissu ressemble très fort à de l'endomètre, mais qu'en fait,
ce serait un petit peu autre chose.
Est-ce que vous avez entendu ça ? Qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ces affirmations-là ?
Donc en fait,
c'est vrai qu'on parle d'un tissu endométrial, mais ce qu'on sait maintenant depuis quand même pas mal d'années, c'est qu'une fois que ce tissu se trouve dans des localisations
anormales, donc par exemple au niveau du péritoine ou sur l'intestin,
ce tissu va provoquer une réaction fibreuse.
Et donc ça veut dire que le tissu hôte, hein, qui est le tissu de la patiente, va réagir par une réaction de fibrose.
Et donc ce tissu va ressembler à ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui de l'adénomyose, qui est un petit peu différent de l'endométriose.
Mais ça, c'est un terme histologique.
Je vais reposer la question pour bien que ce soit clair. Ce tissu, est-ce que c'est de l'endomètre ou est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui ressemble à l'endomètre, mais qui est un petit peu l'endomètre mutant ?
Qu'est-ce que, est-ce que-
Ah non, je ne dirais pas de l'endomètre mutant. Donc c'est vraiment quand on regarde au microscope, hein, puisque nous faisons beaucoup de prélèvements histologiques, donc on regarde ce qu'on prélève au microscope.
Et donc on reconnaît très clairement le tissu endométrial, donc qui est composé de glandes et de cellules stromales. Mais la différence par rapport à la situation utopique, donc dans la cavité utérine,
au niveau des lésions d'endométriose, ce tissu est entouré d'une fibrose.
Donc on va pas parler de mutant.
Donc petite différence, mais ça reste.
Oui, exactement.
Ça reste de l'endomètre.
Tout à fait.
Dans cette famille-là. J'ai pu lire aussi que certains qualifient l'endométriose de tumeur bénigne. Alors, ça fait peur tout de suite, ces appellations qui font penser au cancer.
Est-ce qu'il y a une vérité là-dedans ? Est-ce qu'on peut parler de tumeur bénigne pour parler de l'endométriose ?
Tout à fait. Donc le terme tumeur bénigne est bien choisi puisque finalement, l'endométriose, on la détecte à l'examen clinique parce que justement, y a un développement tumoral.
Donc y a une masse que l'on palpe. Donc toute masse est caractérisée par une tumeur et bénigne parce que l'endométriose ne va jamais, ou quasiment jamais, se transformer en cancer, sauf de rares cas à la ménopause.
Par contre, tumeur fait évidemment référence au cancer. On sait que les cellules endométriales qui sont en situation ectopique ont des caractéristiques des cellules cancéreuses.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'elles peuvent se multiplier. Elles vont adhérer au tissu, elles vont infiltrer le tissu, provoquer ce qu'on appelle une angiogenèse, donc un développement de nouveaux vaisseaux.
Ce sont des cellules qui vont passer dans les vaisseaux lymphatiques, dans la vascularisation, pour atteindre d'autres organes.
Mais il faut se rassurer, car ces cellules n'ont jamais un potentiel cancéreux. Donc, elles ont des caractéristiques de structure, si vous voulez, de fonctionnement, mais jamais ne mettront la vie de la patiente en danger.
Très bien. Donc, il y a ce tissu qui est là où il ne devrait pas être. Qu'est-ce qu'il entraîne alors ? Des lésions, c'est ça ?
C'est ça. Donc en fait, d'un point de vue histologique, je viens donc de vous dire que cette lésion va s'entourer de fibrose et cette fibrose va, par exemple, provoquer, si elle se trouve au niveau de l'intestin,
des rétrécissements, par exemple, de la lumière intestinale, des rétrécissements au niveau de l'uretère, au niveau de la vessie.
Donc finalement, ce sont les patientes qui vont ressentir des douleurs ou des répercussions en fonction de l'organe qui sera atteint.
D'accord. L'endométriose, alors, ça ne touche que les femmes ? Parce que j'ai pu entendre dire que ça pouvait, dans certains cas, concerner aussi les hommes.
C'est une question un petit peu piège, monsieur.
D'accord. Je suis là pour ça.
Oui, oui, clairement, c'est vrai qu'il existe dans la littérature quelques rares cas, mais vraiment exceptionnels, d'endométriose au niveau de la prostate chez l'homme, mais c'est quelque chose d'assez exceptionnel.
Donc, je pense qu'on peut oublier. Je pense que l'homme, contrairement à la femme, ne souffre pas d'endométriose.
Mmmh. Bon, donc c'est-- vous vous êtes d'abord nuancée en disant : « C'est dans quelques cas très rares » et puis plus affirmative en disant-
Oui.
...ce n'est jamais le cas.
Non, ben, je pense que dans la littérature, c'est vrai que si on va fouiller, hein, aujourd'hui ensemble, on va trouver peut-être un case report, mais je pense qu'on ne peut pas parler d'infection masculine.
Très bien. Donc, du tissu qui est en dehors des cavités utérines, là où il ne devrait pas être, qui cause ensuite des lésions aux organes autour, donc par exemple l'intestin, par exemple la vessie, l'uretère.
Ça entraîne une série de douleurs chez la personne, chez la femme. Qu'est-ce qu'on fait à ce stade-là, en termes de traitement ?
Donc c'est vrai que le premier symptôme, ou un des symptômes de l'endométriose, c'est en tout cas la douleur qui peut arriver très tôt chez les jeunes filles.
Ben donc c'est sûr que toute douleur va être traitée par des antidouleurs, donc soit des anti-inflammatoires. Clairement, les patientes qui vont avoir des douleurs en relation avec les règles, on
va leur proposer un traitement hormonal, justement pour diminuer l'importance des règles ou bien pour supprimer les règles et provoquer ce qu'on appelle
une aménorrhée, donc une absence de règles.
Donc, si les patientes ne sont plus réglées, ben probablement qu'elles n'auront plus mal. Par contre, nous avons d'autres symptômes dont on parlera qui ne seront pas clairement traités par un traitement hormonal.
D'accord. Est-ce qu'il y a d'autres traitements ? Puisque j'ai pu entendre dire que la voie chirurgicale était parfois explorée.
Qu'est-ce que vous en pensez ?
Bien sûr, en tant que chirurgienne, je vais vous répondre par l'affirmative, bien sûr, mais en tant que chirurgiens, nous préconisons toujours un traitement médical de première intention.
Pourquoi ? Parce que nous avons un certain pourcentage de patientes qui vont être tout à fait
soulagées par le traitement hormonal et donc inutile de les envoyer au bloc opératoire pour une intervention qui, malgré tout, peut entraîner éventuellement des complications ou une morbidité, en tout cas possible.
Je pense comprendre qu'il y a de nombreuses théories en ce qui concerne les causes. Donc, vous évoquiez tout à l'heure que c'est encore très flou.
Et je pense comprendre aussi que selon la théorie que le médecin va avoir vis-à-vis de la cause, la piste envisagée pour le traitement va être un petit peu différente.
Non. En fait, la cause la plus acceptée aujourd'hui, la présence de ce tissu en situation ectopique, c'est le reflux par les trompes.
Hein, donc normalement, l'endomètre va s'écouler par le vagin et provoquer des règles. Ce tissu, on le sait, peut régurgiter, donc passer à travers les trompes et se retrouver dans la cavité péritonéale, donc abdominale, chez 80 % des patientes.
Donc ça, c'est la théorie du reflux tubaire. C'est la théorie qui est connue depuis plus de cent ans, qui est la théorie la plus acceptée actuellement.
Mmmh.
Par contre, y a d'autres théories comme la théorie des cellules souches, la théorie, euh-
J'ai pu entendre parler de la théorie métaplasique.
Oui, exactement. J'étais une défenseuse de la théorie métaplasique en 1986, c'est-à-dire que le tissu normal, donc le tissu séromique, hein, qui tapisse la cavité péritonéale, va se transformer en lésion d'endométriose ou des
lésions, l'épithélium qui tapisse l'ovaire peut se transformer en endométriose.
Mais je dirais qu'une fois que la lésion est installée, peu importe la cause, le traitement sera le même, soit médical, soit chirurgical, soit médico-chirurgical, associant traitement médical et traitement chirurgical.
D'accord.
Il existe encore d'autres causes, hein, mais peut-être qu'il ne faut pas rentrer dans tous les détails de ces causes puisqu'elles sont-
Si ça vous paraît pertinent, on peut l'explorer.
Pertinent, je ne crois pas, hein. Donc, mais bon, peut-être pour expliquer certaines localisations un petit peu plus complexes, comme par exemple les lésions qui se trouvent au niveau de la plèvre et du poumon.
Vous pourriez me dire : « Ben, ce n'est pas dans la cavité péritonéale. Comment les lésions, ces cellules peuvent atteindre les poumons ?
» Hein, parce qu'il y a quand même le diaphragme qui sépare les deux cavités, la cavité abdominale et la cavité thoracique.
Donc, on a la théorie, par exemple, de la dissémination vasculaire. Donc, ces cellules peuvent passer dans les vaisseaux et atteindre comme ça d'autres organes à distance du pelvis, donc à distance de l'utérus.
Et donc, vous étiez une défenseuse de la théorie métaplasique en 86. Vous avez depuis changé d'avis, c'est ça que je comprends ?
Ben, vous comprenez bien entre les lignes, hein, clairement. C'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui, je suis plus convaincue de la théorie du reflux tubaire comme décrit, hein, par Samson en 1902 ou en 1920, je ne sais plus exactement.
Pourquoi ? Parce qu'en fait, la théorie de la métaplasie, très souvent, ne permet pas d'expliquer l'importance des adhérences que l'on observe lorsqu'on propose une intervention chirurgicale chez les patientes.
Alors que la théorie du reflux tubaire, on sait que le sang menstruel va provoquer une inflammation. Cette inflammation va guérir par la formation d'adhérences.
La métaplasie, c'est un tissu qui se transforme, donc y a pas de raison que ce soit aussi inflammatoire et aussi adhérentiel.
Et donc, la théorie du reflux, alors, part du principe que l'endométriose est renforcée, pour ainsi dire, elle est amplifiée, voilà, par le cycle menstruel, c'est ça ?
Donc, perte de sang, euh-
Tout à fait.
Voilà.
Mais alors, j'ai pu lire qu'on avait pu observer parfois des lésions, voilà, liées à l'endométriose chez des fœtus.
Oui, là, vous avez lu la théorie, 'fin, vraiment la littérature très très très récente, hein, monsieur, puisque effectivement, y a une théorie qui a été décrite, bah, il y a peut-être un an ou deux.
Donc, vous êtes bien à jour dans votre littérature, qui montre qu'effectivement, les fœtus ou les nouveau-nés, petites filles qui ont des saignements à la naissance,
étant donné le statut anatomique de l'utérus, on a plus de reflux de,
de tissu endométrial à la naissance, parce que finalement, l'endomètre de la petite fille va être sous l'influence des hormones de la maman.
Donc cet endomètre qui va proliférer, ben, peut passer par les trompes et s'implanter sur le péritoine. Et donc on peut observer comme ça chez les enfants, même avant la puberté, des petites lésions,
ou implantation de cellules souches ou cellules mésenchymateuses, qui par la suite pourront se développer en endométriose suite à la stimulation hormonale lors de la puberté.
D'accord. Et donc le cycle menstruel, les pertes de sang vont causer ce reflux, causer cette-- endommager encore plus les lésions, si je comprends bien, je ne dis pas de bêtises ?
Ou elles vont en provoquer d'autres.
Voilà, c'est ça.
Hein, donc on pourrait dire qu'y a peut-être des petites lésions un peu disséminées, mais le reflux menstruel va amplifier, hein, le nombre de lésions.
Et en fait, un argument qui
prouve un petit peu cette théorie, c'est que les jeunes filles qui ont des troubles de l'écoulement du flux menstruel, par exemple par des malformations du système génital, donc on peut penser par exemple à une sténose du vagin
ou une absence partielle du vagin, ben, au moment des règles, ces patientes ne vont pas présenter de règles puisque le vagin est sténosé.
Par contre, elles vont avoir du reflux tubaire plus important. Et chez ces jeunes patientes, on trouve un taux important d'endométriose.
Donc ça, c'est aussi quelque chose qui a été décrit et qui prouve bien la relation règle et développement de l'endométriose.
Et encore avant ça, il y a donc, si je comprends bien, donc déjà chez certaines très jeunes filles, chez certains nourrissons, déjà des traces d'endométriose à petite échelle.
Mais alors, est-ce que donc, ça ne permet pas de se pencher vers une cause génétique, un truc héréditaire, quelque chose de peut-être environnemental ?
Où est-ce qu'on en est à ce niveau-là ?
Tout à fait. Donc ici, on a évoqué plutôt les saignements de la petite fille en période néonatale. Donc ça, c'est quelque chose qui est prouvé, hein, donc les mamans s'en souviennent.
Et c'est vrai que vous attirez l'attention sur le problème génétique. Ça, c'est aussi quelque chose qui est bien connu.
En fait, on sait que les filles de mères qui ont été atteintes d'endométriose ont sept fois plus de risques d'être atteintes d'endométriose.
Alors, c'est sûr que vous parlez aussi de l'environnement et c'est sûr que les perturbateurs endocriniens, on en parle de plus en plus.
Et c'est sûr que probablement, ça peut expliquer le nombre impressionnant de patientes qui souffrent aujourd'hui d'endométriose par rapport aux patientes que l'on voyait fin des années 80, par exemple, hein, puisqu'on voit quand même
un pourcentage très très élevé de patientes qui en souffrent.
J'ai l'impression qu'à chaque fois que j'interviewe un médecin, que ce soit au sujet de, voilà, ici, l'endométriose ou le diabète ou le cancer ou quoi que ce soit, toujours, ça revient toujours.
C'est les perturbateurs endocriniens, la pollution, la mauvaise alimentation, etc.
'Fin, j'ai l'impression que c'est à la fois quelque chose dont tout le monde est certain et en même temps quelque chose qui reste très mystérieux et très opaque.
Bah disons que c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu mystérieux puisque, bon, les travaux que l'on essaye de mener pour montrer les différences, hein, par exemple,
de niveaux de perturbateurs endocriniens chez les femmes qui ont de l'endométriose et celles qui n'en ont pas, on a des difficultés pour le prouver par des prises de sang et des mesures toxicologiques.
C'est très difficile à prouver. Maintenant, on sait que ces perturbateurs endocriniens ont quand même un rôle au niveau de l'imprégnation oestrogénique des lésions.
Et donc, comme c'est une pathologie oestrogéno-dépendante, on fait le lien très rapidement. Maintenant, clairement, si on interroge les patientes qui ont de l'endométriose, c'est parfois difficile de leur dire
: « Ah ben oui, c'est parce que vous mangez ceci, c'est parce que vous utilisez des produits plastiques que vous avez développé de l'endométriose.
» On n'arrive pas à faire ce lien aussi directement.
Mais alors, justement, on passe un petit peu du coq à l'âne, mais parce que donc on ne l'a pas encore dit, mais l'endométriose, a priori, ne se guérit pas.
C'est quelque chose qu'on connaît à vie, sauf, voilà, si on arrive peut-être à trouver un traitement qui annule les symptômes, mais en tout cas, la maladie en elle-même reste.
Quand vous avez cette fameuse consultation, vous devez annoncer à la patiente qu'elle est malade à vie, qu'elle va connaître une endométriose et tous les symptômes qui sont associés.
Comment ça se passe psychologiquement ? Comment vous vous y prenez ?
Disons que ce n'est pas le message que je vais faire passer.
D'accord.
Clairement, je vais pas dire à une patiente : « Waouh, vous avez de l'endométriose, ma chère madame, c'est pour toute la vie. »
Hm, hm. Bien sûr.
Je pense quand même qu'en tant que médecin, en tant que chirurgien, en tout cas, on peut être un peu convaincu du bien-fondé de notre pratique. C'est sûr qu'on a des patientes qui ont des récidives.
On peut pas dire : « Ici, à la Citadelle, y a 0 % de récidive. » Clairement, on en a, mais je pense qu'avoir de nombreuses patientes, on améliore la qualité de vie.
Ces patientes qui ont une qualité de vie vraiment perturbée, on les traite médicalement ou de manière chirurgicale. La qualité de vie est tellement améliorée que même s'il reste encore un peu de douleur, la vie est transformée.
Donc, je pense qu'il ne faut pas annoncer en disant : « C'est une fatalité et c'est comme ça jusqu'à la ménopause. »
OK. Donc j'étais peut-être un peu trop fataliste dans mon approche.
Un petit peu.
Et donc finalement, psychologiquement, ça se passe bien ?
Mais en fait,
c'est un petit peu paradoxal ce que je vais vous dire, mais les patientes sont souvent très contentes qu'on mette
le doigt sur le diagnostic puisque ce sont des patientes, comme vous le savez certainement, si vous avez relu la littérature,
ce sont des patients qui ont consulté de nombreux médecins.
On leur a toujours dit : « C'est dans la tête, vous n'avez rien, c'est normal d'avoir mal pendant les règles. » Et un jour, elles se présentent dans un centre où on traite l'endométriose de manière plus fréquente.
Et là, tout de suite, on met le doigt sur le diagnostic. On annonce. Donc les patientes sont contentes d'avoir enfin un nom sur leur problème.
Est-ce que vous diriez qu'on a tendance dans notre société à faire une association entre la féminité et... On associe le fait d'être une femme à une douleur intrinsèque.
Est-ce que vous diriez que c'est juste ?
C'est peut-être pas tout à fait faux. Je pense quand même que, bon, y a eu beaucoup de gynécologues hommes.
D'accord, oui.
Beaucoup de gynécologues hommes. Aujourd'hui, ça a changé. On voit dans les jeunes,
les jeunes assistants en formation une proportion de femmes plus importante et probablement que les femmes sont plus sensibles à la douleur parce qu'elles-mêmes ont peut-être mal également.
Lors de votre promotion, vous étiez une minorité de femmes ?
Non. Minorité, non, ça change. Attendez, je me souviens plus très bien, mais je pense qu'on était peut-être 40 %, 60 %.
Je dirais à la grosse louche, je me souviens plus.
60 % d'hommes.
Oui, c'est ça. 40 % de femmes. Aujourd'hui, c'est 80 % de femmes et 20 % d'hommes.
D'accord, oui.
Le nombre de gynécologues que nous formons ici à Liège, c'est 90 % de femmes.
Oui. Et dans le cadre de la gynécologie, comment est-ce que vous expliquez ce shift, ce changement ?
Ben, c'est un petit peu partout dans la médecine en fait. Donc la médecine, vous savez, ce sont des études longues et quand même difficiles.
Les filles sont quand même plus scolaires que les messieurs. Je vois que vous tiquez.
Non, mais c'est intéressant. Une généralisation comme ça, ouais.
Non, mais je dis pas ça comme ça, mais je veux dire que bon, la médecine attire en tout cas actuellement plus de femmes.
Je dis pas que les femmes sont plus intelligentes que les messieurs, mais les messieurs se tournent sans doute vers...
Non, mais je dirais, oui. Ce qui est intéressant aussi, c'est quand on regarde la médecine, on peut remarquer que selon les spécialisations, par exemple, je crois qu'en chirurgie, ça reste encore très dominé par les hommes.
Et donc, ce qui est intéressant, c'est de voir qu'autrefois, la gynécologie était dominée largement par les hommes, et aujourd'hui, c'est le contraire.
Exact.
Et donc c'est intéressant de voir qu'est-ce qui fait que la gynécologie... Donc ouais, c'est simplement le fait que c'est quelque chose de fondamentalement féminin, quoi. Et alors, le...
Ben je crois que l'attrait de la gynécologie, c'est un petit peu l'aspect,
vraiment multifonction, puisque bon, nous avons des gynécologues qui vont faire que de l'endocrinologie, donc ils vont s'occuper uniquement des problèmes d'endocrinologie, de ménopause, de contraception.
Nous avons des obstétriciens qui vont se concentrer aux accouchements. Donc on a la possibilité de s'orienter et vraiment de se focaliser dans un domaine bien précis de la gynécologie.
Donc, je pense que ça peut être un attrait, en tout cas, toutes les jeunes filles qui postulent, en tout cas, nous l'expliquent.
Voilà. Donc c'était pour la petite parenthèse étude de genre. Vous expliquez que vos patientes, généralement, quand vous les recevez, ressentent un énorme soulagement parce que ça fait 20 ans, voire plus, voire moins, enfin...
En général, cinq, sept ans.
Cinq, sept ans.
Bien sûr, elles sont contentes, mais un peu fâchées malgré tout.
Oui, en colère contre le...
La première réaction, c'est de dire : « Ben enfin, quelqu'un qui m'a écoutée, qui a trouvé ce que j'avais. » Ou quelqu'un, bon, ça peut être moi, ça peut être l'équipe, bien sûr.
Et d'autre part, comment est-ce possible que les précédents n'aient pas fait le diagnostic aussi vite ?
Et donc, c'est la question que je vais vous poser. Comment expliquer ça ?
Comment expliquer ça ? Ben, je pense que le secret, pour poser un diagnostic d'endométriose, c'est d'écouter les patientes.
Donc c'est sûr que si vous n'avez pas le temps de consulter, que le fait que la patiente se plaigne de douleur vous dérange, ben certainement, vous n'allez pas trouver ni poser de diagnostic d'endométriose.
Donc, il suffit d'interroger les patientes et de se dire : « Bon, ben elle a tous les symptômes qui correspondent aux symptômes de l'endométriose.
» Et en faisant un examen clinique et puis des examens complémentaires, on peut évidemment arriver assez rapidement au diagnostic.
Donc, est-ce qu'il faut en conclure que pendant très longtemps, on n'écoutait pas les patientes ?
Ben je pense qu'encore aujourd'hui.
D'accord.
Donc ce n'est pas une histoire du passé, c'est encore une histoire d'aujourd'hui.
Donc les patientes nous le disent : « Mon gynécologue ou ma gynécologue me confirme qu'avoir des douleurs pendant les règles, c'est quelque chose que les femmes ont connu depuis toujours et que je ne dois pas exagérer.
C'est normal d'avoir mal. » Maintenant, quand on évalue la douleur d'une patiente, on essaye quand même de voir l'importance de la douleur et l'impact sur sa vie de tous les jours.
Mmh.
C'est ça qui est important. Avoir un peu mal, ce n'est pas grave, mais avoir mal au point de ne pas quitter son lit, ce n'est pas normal.
Oui. Et donc cette association entre avoir ses règles et ressentir des douleurs, c'est normal, y a pas de souci.
Vous dites qu'aujourd'hui, c'est encore toujours le cas, qu'on ne prend toujours pas vraiment, de manière générale, le temps d'écouter la patiente.
Et même au-delà de cela, est-ce que ces médecins sont au courant, savent ce qu'est l'endométriose ou bien est-ce que c'est quelque chose
qui reste... Est-ce que c'est enseigné en fac de médecine aujourd'hui de manière approfondie ou pas ?
Ben je dirais que c'est enseigné de manière approfondie, c'est plus quand les personnes s'orientent déjà vers la gynécologie.
Oui, oui.
Mais je dirais que certains médecins traitants connaissent très très bien les symptômes d'endométriose. On fait des conférences, justement, visées, pas grand public, mais pour les médecins généralistes.
Et certains médecins généralistes sont vraiment alertés par les symptômes de leurs patients. Donc tout dépend un petit peu de la personnalité du médecin qui reçoit la patiente, clairement.
Mais c'est enseigné. Peut-être pas assez encore.
Donc, la patiente arrive chez vous,
elle est soulagée de trouver enfin une solution. Et à ce moment-là, vous allez lui proposer un traitement, donc généralement, a priori, plutôt hormonal et éventuellement, si ça ne marche pas, un traitement chirurgical.
Donc voilà, pour prendre les choses un petit peu dans l'ordre, le traitement hormonal, on parle de généralement prendre la pilule, si je comprends bien.
C'est ça, tout à fait. Donc en fait, le but de ce traitement hormonal va être de supprimer la présence de règles.
Donc on va expliquer aux patientes que ne pas être réglée pendant trois mois, parce que c'est souvent la période d'essai de ce traitement médical. Donc on va leur
proposer un traitement, une pilule, soit
avec des œstrogènes et des progestatifs, soit une pilule progestative, ça, c'est un petit peu au choix du gynécologue, et de revoir les patientes après trois mois et de voir l'évolution de la symptomatologie après ces trois mois.
Mais donc une pilule qui contient des œstrogènes. Vous disiez justement que l'endométriose réagit aux œstrogènes.
Exactement. C'est une pathologie œstrogénodépendante.
Je me demandais pourquoi vous rigolez.
C'est parce que vous posez les bonnes questions. Je vois que vous avez bien travaillé votre sujet, monsieur. C'est sûr que c'est œstrogénodépendant, mais en fait, il faut savoir que la femme a quand même besoin d'œstrogènes.
Donc si vous lui administrez que des progestatifs, on va bloquer l'activité des ovaires. Donc ces ovaires ne vont plus sécréter d'œstrogènes.
Par contre, la patiente va recevoir des progestatifs et ces progestatifs vont calmer les lésions d'endométriose. Elles vont empêcher la prolifération des lésions.
Donc d'un point de vue traitement de l'endométriose, les progestatifs, c'est le mieux. Par contre, les patientes vont se sentir moins bien parce qu'elles sont un peu privées d'œstrogènes.
Or, les œstrogènes, ce sont les hormones féminines par excellence. Donc quand on propose une pilule soit progestative, soit œstroprogestative,
les œstroprogestatives, ben c'est pour le bien-être de la patiente, tout en sachant qu'en donnant des pilules œstroprogestatives, on va quand même administrer de manière exogène des œstrogènes, mais pas en forte dose, donc ce n'est pas trop grave.
Donc oui, donc les œstrogènes qu'on administre sont là pour le confort de la patiente et idéalement, ne vont pas exciter l'endométriose pour réveiller les douleurs.
Exactement.
Ça va, j'ai bien compris. Un autre traitement hormonal, je crois, plus rare, mais qui arrive parfois, c'est d'administrer de la testostérone.
Est-ce que ça arrive parfois ?
Non, en fait, non. Enfin, nous, en tout cas, dans notre centre, nous ne proposons pas de testostérone aux patientes.
Ben, vous connaissez les effets de la testostérone. Donc la testostérone, ce sont des androgènes. Je crois qu'il y a aucune femme qui a envie de recevoir des androgènes en quantité subphysiologique.
Alors, je vais vous chercher les cas un peu exceptionnels.
Mais donc, il existe et j'en connais, des personnes, des hommes transgenres, donc qui alors souhaitent recevoir des androgènes et souhaitent se débarrasser de leur endométriose.
Est-ce que... enfin, ce que j'ai pu lire, en fait, c'est que dans ces cas-là, la testostérone faisait un peu d'une pierre deux coups.
Si vous voulez. C'est vrai que bon, les progestatifs qu'on utilise aujourd'hui, les plus anciens ont quand même des effets androgéniques.
Donc androgènes, testostérone, mais avec des effets secondaires importants. Donc raucité de la voix, pilosité. Donc, ce sont des effets secondaires que les femmes ne souhaitent pas avoir.
Donc actuellement, les indications de testostérone par voie orale chez la femme, il y en a pas. On a parfois des indications de traitements locaux par testostérone, mais chez les patientes plus âgées.
Donc dans l'endométriose, moi, je crois qu'on peut vraiment oublier.
Oui, donc sauf peut-être alors dans les cas, donc transgenres ou des choses comme ça.
Attendez, j'ai pas tout à fait bien suivi. Les hommes transgenres qui auraient de l'endométriose, attendez...
Donc ce sont des personnes qui sont nées avec un vagin et donc un utérus, etc., qui développent de l'endométriose et qui souhaitent devenir...
C'est ça.
...un homme et donc prendre de la testostérone.
Bien sûr, ils peuvent avoir de la testostérone, oui. Enfin, je pense aussi qu'on va probablement leur proposer une hystérectomie.
Donc, on va enlever l'utérus, on va enlever les ovaires. Donc, on va déjà enlever une bonne source du problème, en fait.
OK. Et donc, superbe transition vers la question de la chirurgie. J'ai pu voir que certaines patientes, notamment en France, choisissaient donc de se faire retirer l'utérus pour essayer de se débarrasser du problème.
Est-ce que c'est une bonne solution ? Est-ce que ça marche ?
Je ne pense pas que ce soit une bonne solution. En tout cas,
pas de première intention. Donc c'est sûr que nous avons également ici des patientes qui nous demandent de faire une hystérectomie, donc pour supprimer la présence de cet endomètre et la récidive éventuelle d'endométriose.
Mais je dirais qu'on ne propose jamais ce traitement à une patiente jeune, parce que finalement, l'endométriose, elle atteint des patientes jeunes, souvent avec un désir de grossesse.
Donc, tout à fait illusoire de leur proposer une hystérectomie pour mettre un point final à leur pathologie.
Mh.
Donc ça, c'est plutôt réservé à des patients qui ont été multi-opérés, qui arrivent en fin de parcours ou après 40 ans, qui ont eu leur enfant ou pas leur enfant.
Et après discussions multiples, on peut éventuellement proposer une hystérectomie, mais ce n'est certainement pas le premier choix.
Oui, c'est a priori logique parce que c'est un choix assez définitif.
Exact.
On va revenir sur la question de la grossesse, mais avant ça, vous parlez de patientes qui arrivent en fin de parcours.
Est-ce que la ménopause, et donc la fin des règles, puisque vous parliez d'une aménorrhée tout à l'heure, donc une absence de cycle menstruel.
La ménopause, c'est l'aménorrhée naturelle, pour ainsi dire. Est-ce que la ménopause résout le problème ?
C'est sûr que c'est souvent un langage que l'on tient aux patientes en disant : « Bon ben, si vous tenez le coup encore un petit peu, la ménopause arrivant, ben les lésions ne seront plus stimulées.
» Maintenant, il faut savoir qu'à la ménopause, certaines patientes vont demander un traitement hormonal étant donné les effets secondaires de la ménopause, comme les bouffées de chaleur.
Donc forcément, ce sera de nouveau des œstrogènes qui vont pouvoir influencer les lésions résiduelles. On sait de plus que les lésions, à la post-ménopause, peuvent quand même éventuellement se cancériser, notamment au niveau des ovaires.
C'est rare, mais c'est quelque chose qui existe. Donc, je pense qu'il ne faut pas se dire : « La ménopause est le point final de mon endométriose.
» Et d'autre part, si vous avez lu la littérature, on a quand même vu aussi que des patientes en post-ménopause avaient une évolution de leur endométriose.
Pourquoi ? Ben parce que nous avons une possible source d'œstrogènes autre que les ovaires.
Donc les patientes qui sont un petit peu bien enveloppées peuvent avoir une transformation des androgènes en œstrogènes et ces œstrogènes peuvent de nouveau restimuler les lésions d'endométriose.
Donc, je pense pas qu'il faille attendre la ménopause en se disant : « Chouette, ça va bientôt s'arrêter. »
J'essaie de tout remettre un peu dans l'ordre. Si la première solution qu'on conseille, c'est donc une aménorrhée et que chez ces patientes-là, donc ménopausées, vous disiez, dans des situations où
les androgènes vont se transformer en œstrogènes,
qu'est-ce qu'on peut leur administrer comme traitement vu qu'ils ont déjà une absence de règles ?
Oui, mais ça, il faut pas non plus...
Elles ont déjà une absence de règles.
...mais elles sont pas toutes... En fait, quand on parle de cette source d'œstrogènes à partir des adipocytes, donc à partir de la graisse,
bon, toutes les patientes endométriosiques jeunes n'ont pas un tissu adipeux au point d'avoir une source complémentaire d'œstrogènes.
Donc je pense qu'il...
C'est plutôt rare, hein, ça, j'ai bien compris.
...c'est plutôt rare. Oui, c'est plutôt rare.
C'est plutôt rare, mais donc...
C'est plutôt un cas où...
...dans ces cas où ça arrive.
Oui, alors à ce moment-là, nous, on va pas savoir doser, hein, cette sécrétion d'œstrogènes. Donc la patiente va sans doute revenir en nous disant : « Je suis sans règles, mais j'ai toujours mal.
» Maintenant, elles peuvent avoir mal parce que les lésions fibreuses dont on a parlé tout à l'heure sont toujours bien présentes parce qu'elles ne vont jamais disparaître.
Donc la patiente va se rendre compte-
Elles vont jamais disparaître ?
Non.
À moins d'une opération chirurgicale.
Exact.
Voilà, donc ça va peut-être être ça la solution du coup.
Tout à fait. Donc en fait, les travaux que j'ai menés en 1986-87, c'était justement des patientes qui avaient reçu des traitements hormonaux de longue durée.
On s'est rendu compte que les lésions persistaient malgré ces traitements hormonaux. Donc effectivement, si la patiente est toujours symptomatique après un long traitement hormonal, la solution devient l'exérèse chirurgicale.
Donc, on va enlever toutes ces lésions d'endométriose.
On parlait tout à l'heure de la question de la grossesse.
Quand une patiente vient avec des plaintes de douleurs, donc liées à l'endométriose, je pense avoir compris que de manière générale, les gynécologues vont essayer de préserver la capacité de reproduction
plutôt que le confort rapide et immédiat et la résolution des douleurs.
Est-ce que je me trompe ?
Je dirais qu'il y a des patientes qui viennent soit pour un problème d'infertilité et d'endométriose, soit des patientes qui viennent pour infertilité et douleur.
Donc la question avec le gynécologue va être très simple. On va donc demander à la patiente : « Qu'est-ce qui est le plus important pour vous ?
C'est d'abord de soulager la douleur ou de traiter l'infertilité ? » Les patientes qui ont des douleurs de longue durée depuis plusieurs années vont nous dire : « Vous me soulagez d'abord et puis je verrai pour ma fertilité. »
Mmm-hmm.
Maintenant, ce qu'il faut savoir aussi, c'est qu'en réséquant l'endométriose de manière chirurgicale, on peut améliorer la fertilité.
Hein, donc je dirais qu'il faut pas nécessairement attendre la douleur pour intervenir chez les patientes.
Oui, mais donc là, je crois qu'on a sauté une étape. Donc l'endométriose, de manière générale, est associée donc à l'infertilité.
Oui.
Comment ça s'explique ?
Ah, y a plusieurs hypothèses de nouveau. Donc l'hypothèse la plus simple, c'est de se dire : « L'endométriose, c'est une maladie inflammatoire, donc elle va provoquer des adhérences.
» Adhérences, donc c'est un accolement anormal entre deux organes. Et les organes gynécologiques, ce sont les ovaires et les trompes.
Donc imaginons une patiente avec un gros kyste d'endométriose, la trompe est tout à fait adhérentielle et donc on aura des problèmes de communication
entre la trompe et l'ovaire, hein, puisque pour obtenir une grossesse, il faut quand même que la trompe puisse aller
aspirer l'ovocyte au niveau de l'ovaire.
Ça, c'est la théorie, je dirais, la plus simple, c'est ce qu'on va appeler les distorsions anatomiques.
Mmm.
Un travail de longue date aussi, c'est de dire : « Les patientes qui ont un petit peu d'endométriose, hein, pas nécessairement des lésions massives, peuvent avoir au niveau du péritoine un état inflammatoire
et cet état inflammatoire va empêcher la fécondation.
» Donc les spermatozoïdes vont pas nécessairement dans la cavité péritonéale, mais les trompes le sont. Et donc y a toute une modification du milieu qui empêche le spermatozoïde de féconder l'ovocyte.
Donc ça, ce sont deux théories. Y a encore d'autres théories qui montrent aussi, par exemple, que les patientes qui ont de l'endométriose ont un problème au niveau de la cavité utérine, donc que l'implantation utérine va se faire moins bien.
Donc il faut peut-être d'abord traiter l'endométriose pour obtenir la grossesse.
Mmm. Encore une fois, j'ai l'impression qu'il y a un ensemble de théories.
Oui.
Est-ce que ce ne serait pas aussi parce que l'endométriose apparaît souvent sous une série de formes différentes, qu'il n'y a pas juste une endométriose, mais un spectre de l'endométriose-
Bien sûr
...et une série de façons différentes dont ça peut se présenter ?
Clairement, clairement. Donc les travaux que j'ai faits y a très longtemps montraient quand même qu'il y avait trois types d'endométriose : l'endométriose sur le péritoine, donc l'endométriose péritonéale,
l'endométriose ovarienne et l'endométriose profonde.
Donc, c'est-à-dire, ce sont des lésions qui vont se trouver sous le péritoine et entraîner de nombreux accolements et de nombreuses adhérences.
Mais il est évident que quand on pose un diagnostic d'endométriose avec toutes les techniques que l'on a actuellement, hein, la radiologie en particulier,
on n'a pas toujours de corrélation entre ce qu'on a décrit en préopératoire et entre ce qu'on trouve au moment de l'opération.
Donc, y a toujours un élément de surprise. Pourquoi ? Parce que l'endométriose, comme vous le dites, a de nombreuses facettes et que parfois, on se trouve en difficulté tellement les lésions sont importantes et adhérentielles.
Une autre chose que j'ai pu lire, c'est que donc au moment justement de l'imagerie médicale, au moment de faire une IRM, la lecture des imageries médicales était pas forcément la plus simple.
Et donc on peut avoir des médecins qui vont regarder une radio et dire : « En fait, pas de problème, je ne vois rien du tout.
» Et puis après une deuxième, une troisième, une quatrième consultation, sur base des mêmes images, on va enfin trouver un médecin ou une médecin qui est en capacité de voir : « Ben si, il est juste là, c'est évident. »
Tout à fait.
« L'endométriose est énorme. »
Tout à fait. Donc je pense que c'est un petit peu comme tout en médecine et dans d'autres professions, certainement, c'est l'expérience qui est importante.
Et c'est sûr qu'un radiologue qui n'a jamais vu d'endométriose à l'IRM, c'est sûr qu'il va avoir des difficultés pour nous la décrire.
Par contre, avec l'expérience, au bout de X mois ou X années, les lésions seront décrites vraiment de manière très très précise.
Alors, vous parlez de l'IRM, il n'y a pas que l'IRM, bien sûr, hein, dans la mise au point radiologique.
Si on veut mettre en évidence des lésions un petit peu plus difficiles à détecter, là, de nouveau, il faut faire appel à des gynécologues qui ont des formations bien particulières en échographie transvaginale à la recherche d'endométriose.
C'est quelque chose d'un peu nouveau.
Quelque chose que j'ai pu remarquer en interrogeant donc des femmes autour de moi, c'est--
donc, en leur expliquant que j'allais interviewer aujourd'hui une médecin spécialisée autour de ces questions, c'est finalement presque une forme de méfiance par rapport au corps médical de se dire : « Mais ils ne comprennent pas.
Ils ne savent pas de quoi il s'agit, vont dire des bêtises », voilà, sur base donc de mauvaises expériences passées.
Est-ce que vous comprenez cette méfiance et comment est-ce que vous, vous réagissez par rapport à ça ?
Bien sûr, je comprends tout à fait. Donc, des patientes nous l'expliquent bien. Elles ont vu plusieurs gynécologues.
À un moment donné, elles se décident à en voir un autre qui dit : « Y a peut-être quelque chose. » Donc c'est sûr que ces patientes qui ont passé des années à se plaindre,
qui n'ont pas été écoutées, clairement, elles sont méfiantes et je comprends tout à fait.
Donc c'est sûr que le fait d'avoir créé ici un centre de référence endométriose est quelque chose qui nous permet de poser des diagnostics très rapidement et d'être en pleine empathie avec ces patientes, hein, parce que bien sûr, on comprend que
il n'est pas du tout normal de rester deux, trois jours par mois à la maison ou, donc, de ne plus aller travailler.
Donc, vraiment d'avoir une qualité de vie complètement perturbée.
Donc, on n'en a pas encore parlé. Donc, centre de référence de l'endométriose, qu'est-ce que ça signifie concrètement et qu'est-ce que ça change sur le, voilà, l'échelle de la Belgique, par exemple ?
L'échelle de la Belgique, je veux pas être au point de dire que ça change tout, évidemment, mais clairement, je pense qu'il est urgent qu'en Belgique, nous ayons quelques centres de référence.
Bon, en Wallonie, y en a pas 36. Y en a quand même, hein, y en a quand même déjà bien deux. Mais je dirais que pour la prise en charge des patientes, c'est optimal.
Pourquoi ? Parce que vous allez y rencontrer des gynécologues qui connaissent la pathologie, qui vont écouter, qui vont poser un diagnostic rapidement, un bilan rapidement, un traitement hormonal ou hormonochirurgical.
Mais d'autre part, ce centre de référence est important puisqu'on travaille de manière multidisciplinaire. Donc c'est-à-dire qu'on va
travailler avec les mêmes radiologues pour mettre au point les lésions, que ce soit IRM ou des examens de l'intestin ou échographie.
On va travailler avec les mêmes chirurgiens. Donc ce sont vraiment un travail multidisciplinaire. Et donc dans ce centre de référence, on a tout un groupe de médecins qui commence à
de mieux en mieux connaître la pathologie et à prendre en charge de mieux en mieux.
Ça permettra quand même d'éviter à des patientes soit de ne pas être prises en charge du tout ou peut-être de manière non optimale.
Donc, a priori, bon, évidemment, vous êtes légèrement biaisée en la matière, mais a priori, le CHR Citadelle à Liège, plutôt une bonne référence en ce qui concerne le traitement ?
Je pense. Mais maintenant, on n'est pas les seuls, hein. Donc, je pense qu'on peut pas non plus, hein, se vanter d'être le seul centre en Belgique, certainement pas.
Mais je vous ai dit, en Wallonie, y en a deux. À Bruxelles, y en a l'un ou l'autre, mais il en manque clairement, clairement parce que-
Et donc justement, ce manque, ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure sur,
voilà, l'ignorance généralisée au sein du corps médical, les idées reçues sur la douleur, la douleur, mais c'est naturel, c'est évident, c'est inévitable.
Est-ce qu'il n'y a pas alors un combat politique à mener au sujet de ces questions ? Et est-ce que vous, vous êtes active à ce niveau-là ou pas du tout ?
Mais en pratique, non. En théorie, c'est sûr qu'on voudrait que les choses changent et on voudrait bien secouer, secouer ce qu'il faut pour que ça change.
Mais je dirais qu'en pratique,
nous sommes tellement le nez dans le guidon, dans la pratique clinique, que clairement, personne ne va commencer à aller voir les politiques et à leur demander : « Tiens, maintenant, il faut que ce soit une maladie reconnue
comme étant chronique.
Il faut des centres de référence où la prise en charge est facilitée. » On ne prend pas le temps, mais clairement, il faudrait le faire.
Mmh. Alors, quoi, ce sont peut-être alors plutôt les patientes frustrées de leurs longues expériences qui vont peut-être mener ce combat-là ou ?
Les patientes sont actives, hein, bien sûr. Y a des associations de patientes endométriose qui ont évidemment des relations, hein, sur les réseaux sociaux qui font bouger les choses.
Mais c'est vrai que les médecins ne prennent pas leur courage, leur bâton de maréchal pour aller défendre ces idées.
Mais c'est sûr que les patientes bougent beaucoup, mais elles sont également au premier plan.
Donc, on va peut-être alors parler un peu des patientes. Donc, je pense comprendre que pour, peut-être pas l'entièreté de, voilà, de patientes, mais pour de nombreuses patientes, je pense comprendre que
c'est presque une identité, le fait d'avoir de l'endométriose.
Certaines vont employer le terme endo girl pour ainsi dire, ou vont employer ce genre de néologisme-là.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous observez, ça, une forme d'appropriation de la maladie ?
La maladie, ça fait partie de moi, ça fait partie de qui je suis ou ?
Ben, je pense qu'y a mon endo, hein. Donc ça, ça veut vraiment dire que c'est mon endométriose. Mais ce sont des patientes, je peux comprendre, hein, qu'elles ont besoin de communiquer entre elles.
Et finalement, le fait de dire : « Bon, on a toutes de l'endométriose et on doit se parler et c'est notre pathologie, on se l'approprie », je peux comprendre.
Idéalement, on arrive à faire disparaître la douleur, donc via une aménorrhée, mais parfois, le parcours vers une résolution est un peu plus long, un peu plus complexe.
Et donc souvent, je pense comprendre qu'on parle de solutions externes comme, je crois, du yoga ou des formes de sport différentes.
Est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler un petit peu ?
Tout à fait. Donc, nous sommes tellement convaincus du bienfait de cette relaxation parce que bon, on n'a pas eu le temps de l'évoquer, mais ces patientes ont des douleurs pelviennes.
Mais bien sûr, les douleurs peuvent irradier vers le périnée et rendre les relations sexuelles difficiles par contracture du périnée.
Et donc, depuis quelques mois, je ne sais plus exactement quand, mais nous organisons donc des séances depuis septembre, voilà.
Depuis septembre, monsieur, nous organisons des séances de yoga ici et les patientes sont très, très demandeuses d'approches un petit peu différentes.
Parce que bien sûr, les hormones, elles en ont eu, de la chirurgie, elles en ont eu. Il reste quand même des douleurs, hein.
On peut pas dire non plus qu'il y a plus-
D'accord
...de douleurs après les opérations. Et elles sont demandeuses soit de kiné périnéale, soit de yoga, donc de prise en charge un petit peu différente.
C'est intéressant parce que tout à l'heure, j'évoquais le fait que c'était finalement quelque chose qui était à vie.
Et vous, vous nuanciez très fort en disant : « Idéalement, le traitement va connaître un succès, on va résoudre le problème.
» Mais maintenant, vous êtes un peu plus nuancée. Vous m'expliquiez que même après traitement médical, même après chirurgie, généralement, inévitablement, restera des douleurs. Donc...
Ben, la nuance, elle est un petit peu double, hein. Je dirais que les patientes qui avaient une douleur vraiment invalidante, qui se trouvent avec une douleur beaucoup moins invalidante, vont déjà être très très satisfaites.
Par contre, cette douleur qui va persister de manière un peu chronique, un peu sourde, je pense qu'à un moment donné, y a quand même quelque chose à leur proposer.
Et là, le yoga a toute sa place.
Oui, mais vous pouvez nous expliquer quel rapport entre le yoga et la résolution de la douleur ?
Ah ben, je pense que y a probablement quand même une orientation différente. En fait, pour répondre à cette question, je pense qu'il faudrait quand même d'abord expliquer
qu'une patiente qui a eu mal pendant X années, on va dire 10 ans, qui a été opérée, nous sommes certains qu'il y a plus de lésions d'endométriose, sont des patientes qui vont toujours avoir mal.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le cerveau garde ce souvenir de la douleur. Donc c'est ce qu'on appelle en anglais la sensitisation.
Donc le cerveau doit un petit peu se dégager de ce souvenir de douleur et probablement que le yoga et toutes ces solutions un peu alternatives sont un moyen d'améliorer ce souvenir de douleur.
Alors, on n'a toujours pas parlé de chiffres. Concrètement, l'endométriose, ça concerne combien de femmes ?
Donc, on peut dire dans la population générale, hein, donc chez la femme en âge de reproduction, on dit grosso modo 10 %.
Mh. Est-ce qu'on est sûr de ces chiffres ? Parce que tout à l'heure, on expliquait que le diagnostic en lui-même, les femmes qui vont voir leur gynécologue, souvent, leur endométriose n'est pas rapidement diagnostiquée.
Donc finalement, ce chiffre de 10 % presque-
C'est ça, il est probablement sous-estimé, hein. Parce que bon, c'est sûr que pour poser un diagnostic d'endométriose, il ne suffit pas d'avoir des symptômes.
Il faut évidemment arriver jusque
dans un centre où on va faire le diagnostic ou chez un médecin. Donc on veut quand même une preuve soit histologique, soit par imagerie radiologique, que cette patiente soit atteinte par l'endométriose, mais probablement que c'est sous-estimé. Maintenant,
ce pourcentage varie en fonction aussi des symptômes des patientes. On peut vous dire, par exemple, que des patientes qui ont les douleurs caractéristiques d'endométriose, on va retrouver de l'endométriose chez 70 % d'entre elles.
Donc, on n'a pas beaucoup de chances de se tromper.
OK.
Par contre, une patiente qui vient pour infertilité, puisqu'on sait que les messieurs sont quand même aussi responsables de l'infertilité d'un couple, on va retrouver de l'endométriose chez plus ou moins 30 % des femmes.
D'accord, OK.
Donc c'est moins fréquent.
Donc
10 %, mais sans doute plus.
À vue de nez, votre conviction à vous, si vous devez faire une estimation, votre conviction personnelle qui ne vaut pas grand-chose scientifiquement, qu'est-ce que vous diriez ?
Bah, je peux pas dire 30 % non plus, donc je dirais probablement 15 %.
15 %, OK. Donc à peu près une femme sur six. Oui, donc c'est énorme. Donc c'est beaucoup plus que, je ne sais pas, les patients diabétiques, les patients qui sont daltoniens.
C'est beaucoup plus que les patients du coronavirus.
C'est ça.
Et pourtant, on n'en parle presque pas. Comment expliquer que ce soit aussi peu médiatisé alors qu'on parle de-
Ben, on fait des-
...de 10, 15 % ?
C'est ça. Ben, on fait des efforts, hein, monsieur. Donc, y a quand même la campagne, hein, d'endométriose qui s'est tenue cette semaine.
On organise ce qu'on appelle-
Le timing est complètement hasardeux parce que je n'étais pas au courant, mais d'accord.
On organise ce qu'on appelle le festival Image et Santé. Donc l'endométriose sera mise à l'honneur. Donc,
on essaie de mettre l'endométriose au goût du jour, mais c'est clair que les mentalités doivent changer partout. Au niveau-
Les mentalités, c'est-à-dire ?
Au niveau médical, donc tous les médecins doivent être un peu interpellés par les patientes, que ce soit des médecins généralistes ou des gynécologues.
Et même les gastro-entérologues, actuellement, sont sensibilisés. Donc en fait, notre rôle à nous, c'est d'en parler, d'en parler aux sociétés de gastro-entérologie.
Et grâce à ça, les gastro-entérologues nous envoient des patientes en disant : « J'ai peut-être une patiente qui en souffre ».
Parce que parfois, la distinction entre une pathologie endométriosique et digestive, donc quelqu'un qui a
un dolichocôlon ou un côlon spastique, donc un côlon qui va se spasmer très fort, la distinction n'est pas toujours facile à faire.
Et donc, très souvent, nous envoyons des patientes en gastro-entérologie et eux, actuellement, nous renvoient des patientes en disant : « J'ai peut-être quelqu'un qui souffre d'endométriose.
» Donc, ça se fait petit à petit.
OK, ça se fait petit à petit. Et voilà, pour poursuivre sur l'idée de l'information, est-ce que parfois, vous recevez des patients qui sont mal informés, qui ont des idées reçues fausses ?
Je pense qu'il faut déjà peut-être rassurer les patientes, parce que très souvent, quand elles se disent : « J'ai de l'endométriose stade 4 », parce qu'elles vont quand même voir sur Internet les stades 4.
Oui, alors, oui. Est-ce qu'on peut expliquer ? Qu'est-ce que ce sont que ces histoires de stades de l'endométriose ?
C'est ça. Donc, on peut avoir des évolutions différentes. Et plus le temps avance, probablement que l'endométriose évolue et que le stade évidemment s'aggrave.
Maintenant, ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que les stades dont on dispose ne sont pas excellents. Donc on n'arrive pas toujours à avoir un bon pronostic en fonction de ce stade.
Mais clairement, quelqu'un qui a un stade un, c'est un stade qui est quasiment impossible à détecter sans opérer. Donc sur des patientes qui ont des toutes toutes petites lésions, mais qui peuvent avoir très mal,
parce que ce qu'on n'a pas dit non plus, c'est que l'importance de la douleur n'est pas toujours en relation avec l'importance de l'endométriose.
Par contre, les patientes qui ont des stades quatre parfois se disent : « Ouah, la grossesse, ce sera jamais possible pour moi ».
Ça, je pense qu'il faut un petit peu essayer d'oublier. Et je dirais que le rôle du chirurgien est de dire : « Bon, à la fin de l'opération, une fois que l'endométriose a été réséquée, on évalue ce qu'on appelle un score de
fertilité ».
Et en fonction de ce score, on peut dire : « Voilà, vous, madame, vous devez aller en fécondation in vitro parce que votre score n'est pas bon et vos chances d'être enceinte spontanément sont pas bonnes du tout ».
Par contre, une autre patiente, on va lui dire : « Madame, vous pouvez essayer d'être enceinte spontanément parce que l'intervention s'est bien passée, que nous n'avons pas observé d'effet délétère de la chirurgie ».
Donc, si je comprends bien, ces histoires de stade, on va compter, on va mesurer les lésions partout où elles peuvent se trouver.
Et sur base de ça, on va faire un calcul de stade.
Exact.
Stade un, deux, trois, quatre.
Voilà. Exact.
Qui va donc être corrélé à une facilité ou une impossibilité à tomber enceinte. Mais donc, ce n'est que lié, donc, entre guillemets, aux capacités reproductives.
Il s'agit pas de faire une corrélation entre le stade et les douleurs, le stade et les dangers extérieurs ou quoi.
C'est strictement lié, donc, aux capacités reproductives, ouais.
Tout à fait. Et ce stade, on l'évalue au début de l'intervention, parce qu'évidemment, le but de l'intervention, c'est d'améliorer le stade.
Donc c'est sûr qu'on peut pas dire : « Stade quatre va devenir un stade zéro » parce que bon, on laisse quand même toujours un peu de lésions.
Par contre, on va nettement améliorer
le pelvis et donc on va faciliter la grossesse. Très souvent, une fois que l'intervention est terminée, on propose aux patientes soit d'aller en fécondation in vitro très rapidement parce qu'on sait que ça va être compliqué autrement,
ou bien si on a bon espoir, on va leur demander d'attendre six, neuf mois, car on sait que les grossesses arrivent en général dans l'année qui suit l'intervention.
Pour revenir sur la question des traitements, la pilule, donc sous ses différentes formes, n'est pas toujours bien supportée.
Elle peut entraîner, elle est même souvent, j'ai l'impression, mal supportée et entraîner des effets secondaires assez désagréables, donc des maux de tête ou des
Prises de poids.
Voilà, oui, prises de poids ou des nausées, toute une série de choses.
Tout à fait.
Qu'est-ce qu'on propose à ce moment-là aux patientes qui supportent mal cette prise de pilule ?
Disons que c'est comme toujours quand on prescrit un traitement hormonal à une patiente, que ce soit à visée contraceptive ou ici à visée antidouleur, on ne trouve pas toujours la bonne pilule pour la bonne personne.
Donc, on va d'abord tester pendant trois mois, puis si effectivement, la patiente revient en disant : « J'ai pris trois kilos, j'ai des boutons » et des choses comme ça, on va changer de molécule.
Donc il faut savoir que nous avons quand même une large panoplie de molécules et aujourd'hui, nous avons des médications bien spécifiques pour l'endométriose.
Donc, on a dans ces pilules œstroprogestatives un progestatif qui est vraiment idéal pour les patientes qui ont de l'endométriose puisqu'elles ont
un effet antiangiogénique, c'est-à-dire que ça va diminuer un petit peu le fait d'avoir de l'inflammation ou des vaisseaux.
Donc, y a quand même un large choix de médicaments. On ne trouve pas toujours le premier à la première consultation.
Là, vous dressez un paysage qui est finalement assez positif, un regard assez positif sur l'état des choses en ce qui concerne les différentes pilules qui sont possibles
pour les patientes, qui sont offertes aux patientes.
J'entends parfois des voix beaucoup plus sceptiques, beaucoup plus négatives,
notamment, voilà, des regards critiques sur l'état de l'industrie pharmaceutique qui vont résumer en disant
: « Pour les hommes, on offre toute une série de pilules bleues différentes pour les troubles de l'érection, mais par contre, pour les femmes qui connaissent de l'endométriose, qui supportent mal la pilule,
là, c'est un parcours du combattant et beaucoup moins de recherches, beaucoup moins de possibilités ».
Est-ce que vous êtes d'accord avec ce regard plus critique ?
Bon d'abord, la pilule bleue dont vous parlez pour les hommes, c'est un petit peu une découverte fortuite.
OK.
Donc ça n'a pas été lancé dans ce but-là. Donc c'est un effet positif et tant mieux. Pour l'endométriose, on peut quand même dire qu'on cherche de nouvelles molécules.
Maintenant, des molécules, on n'en a pas non plus trente-six mille, mais le développement de nouvelles combinaisons œstroprogestatives sont quand même sur le marché.
Maintenant, le problème, c'est que certaines médications sont fort coûteuses. Et donc effectivement, on ne peut pas proposer ce genre de traitement en première intention pour toutes les femmes.
Mais donc cette idée que les recherches médicales en ce qui concerne les femmes sont mises au second plan, c'est un mythe ?
Ou bien est-ce qu'il y a une vérité là-dedans ?
'Fin moi, personnellement, je ne suis pas impliquée dans toutes ces recherches de nouvelles molécules, mais je dirais quand même que
le but actuellement est quand même de trouver des molécules avec le moins d'effets secondaires possible en utilisant des œstrogènes naturels plutôt que synthétiques et en utilisant des progestatifs avec le moins d'effets secondaires possible.
Donc, je pense qu'il y a des progrès tout doucement, mais peut-être pas nécessairement en relation avec l'endométriose. L'endométriose n'est pas tellement bien reconnue.
Le cancer, bien sûr. L'endométriose, qui n'est pas du tout une pathologie cancéreuse, on n'a pas beaucoup de finances pour faire de la recherche sur l'endométriose.
OK. Et comment est-ce qu'on explique ça alors que, encore une fois, 10 % sont femmes ?
Mais c'est sûr que les
Y a un marché.
Oui, y a le marché, bien sûr. Puis les patientes qui ont un cancer, bien sûr, un jour, vont décéder. Par contre, les patientes qui ont de l'endométriose, elles vont continuer à souffrir, mais
le décès n'est pas la clé de l'évolution de l'endométriose.
Donc, je pense que sincèrement, toutes les finances pour la recherche, c'est le cancer.
OK, donc c'est la nature finale du cancer qui fait que
Oui, je pense bien
...les finances disponibles sont 'fin
les patients sont prêts à, sont forcés à déverser des sommes beaucoup plus importantes pour trouver une solution, alors que l'endométriose n'étant pas fatale, on a presque envie de dire : « Bon, c'est pas très grave ».
Enfin, en comparaison
Un petit peu, effectivement. Donc tous les, comment je vais dire ? Tous les sources de financement pour la recherche sont plutôt dévolues au développement de la recherche pour le cancer.
Le cancer, ouais, en raison de la
Clairement. De l'impact fatal comme vous disiez, clairement.
Ouais, OK. OK. C'est plutôt triste. Est-ce que vous pensez que, voilà, si on regarde, si on fait un regard vers le futur, est-ce que vous voyez ça évoluer ?
Est-ce que vous pensez que c'est quelque chose qui est amené à changer ?
En fait, je pense que le futur, ce n'est pas peut-être de trouver de nouvelles molécules alors que l'endométriose est développée, mais c'est plutôt de trouver des marqueurs de l'endométriose.
Donc en fait, on cherche et on a cherché ici à l'Université de Liège à détecter ce qu'on appelle des biomarqueurs de l'endométriose.
Donc c'est-à-dire qu'on fait des prises de sang chez des jeunes filles, parce que l'endométriose commence très tôt en fait, dès la puberté ou quelques mois après.
Donc de dépister très rapidement ces patientes pour éviter le délai entre les symptômes et le diagnostic et aussi éviter l'évolution de l'endométriose.
Donc, je pense qu'il faut attaquer non pas le traitement, mais plutôt la prévention et dire : « Voilà, ça, c'est une patiente qui a de l'endométriose ou possiblement va en développer ».
Et grâce aux biomarqueurs que nous allons mettre en évidence, là, nous pourrons administrer des traitements qui sont toujours des traitements actuels.
D'accord. Donc attendez, donc des biomarqueurs dans une prise de sang
Oui, c'est ça
...et non pas via
...imagerie médicale. Et alors ensuite, vous parlez de traitement préventif.
Donc si, imaginons, on sait que l'endométriose commence très tôt après la puberté.
Mmh.
Ça commence à l'adolescence. Et donc c'est-à-dire que vous avez une patiente de 14, 15 ans qui est réglée depuis un an et qui a déjà des douleurs tout à fait caractéristiques.
On lui fait une prise de sang. On dit : « Voilà, elle a un biomarqueur, donc elle est possiblement atteinte déjà d'endométriose ».
On ne va pas opérer à 14, 15 ans. Par contre, on va déjà bloquer ses règles en disant : « C'est une patiente qui, grâce à ça, ne va pas développer d'abord des douleurs pendant quatre, cinq ans avec
une errance diagnostique » et deux, l'évolution de la pathologie, parce que clairement, si on ne fait rien, la pathologie évolue.
Donc ça ne sert à rien de développer des traitements magiques pour un stade avancé alors qu'on devrait peut-être agir plus tôt sur un diagnostic très précoce
Mmh
...et peut-être agir plus vite.
OK. Donc si je reprends un petit peu, de façon synthétique, les choses depuis le début,
des patientes femmes, sauf très rares exceptions, qui donc vont avoir des marqueurs héréditaires qui vont sans doute les amener plus tard dans leur vie à connaître une endométriose,
au moment de la puberté, donc, vont commencer à peut-être développer ces biomarqueurs dont vous parliez, qu'on va pouvoir remarquer au sein d'une prise de sang.
Donc à ce moment-là, ça signifierait qu'on espère les trouver un peu par hasard au moment d'une prise de sang ou bien est-ce que ça signifierait alors mener des campagnes de grande échelle chez ces jeunes adolescentes pour essayer de trouver
C'est ça
...ces futures patientes pour endométriose ? Est-ce que...
C'est ça. Donc c'est pas une prise de sang par hasard.
Mmh.
Donc ça doit être vraiment indiqué puisque bon, ce seront des prises de sang, bon, elles ne sont pas encore disponibles actuellement.
Donc je pense qu'on
On parle du futur, ouais
...voilà, dans le futur, ce seront des prises de sang qui seront réservées à des patientes qui, possiblement, ont un diagnostic d'endométriose, comme on fait actuellement pour le cancer.
C'est pour ça qu'on parlait d'essayer de les trouver, justement.
Mmh.
Donc c'est des prises de sang pour trouver des patientes qui, peut-être, plus tard, auront de l'endométriose.
C'est ça. Donc ce sont des patientes qui sont symptomatiques. Donc
Déjà, oui.
Ah oui, oui, oui.
OK.
Des symptômes de l'endométriose. En fait, y a des papiers dans la littérature qui montrent bien que les patientes qu'on opère maintenant à 25 ou à 30 ans sont toutes des patientes qui ont développé des douleurs très vite après
les premières règles, sont des patientes à qui on a dû prescrire la pilule très tôt parce que justement, elles avaient très mal, sont des patientes qui devaient quitter l'école tellement elles avaient mal.
Donc on sait que ça commence très tôt.
Donc le fait de proposer une prise de sang à
une jeune fille qui a déjà ces symptômes alors que la radiologie est négative et qu'on ne va pas les opérer pour bien prouver qu'elles ont de l'endométriose, on peut imaginer de faire une prise de sang.
Dans cette prise de sang, on peut détecter oui ou non la présence du biomarqueur. Et si le biomarqueur est positif, on peut déjà les orienter vers un traitement à visée d'aménorrhée, donc de bloquer les règles assez rapidement.
Ouais, et donc tout ça requiert évidemment des médecins, des gynécologues qui sont à l'écoute de leurs jeunes patientes et qui ne vont pas simplement leur dire : « Non, voilà, les premières règles, c'est douloureux, c'est normal ».
Donc j'ai l'impression que
la recherche pour trouver des solutions vis-à-vis des biomarqueurs, vis-à-vis des prises de sang, vous êtes presque plus positive à ce niveau-là en vous disant : « Voilà, dans un futur, on va finir par y arriver ».
Vous êtes plus positive à ce niveau-là que vis-à-vis du corps médical qui doit encore être remis en question, qui doit apprendre à mieux écouter les jeunes patientes.
Oui, mais je crois que les deux vont se faire en même temps. Ne soyons quand même pas trop négatifs.
Vous êtes optimiste à ce niveau-là aussi ?
Oui, oui, oui. Oui, parce que bon, vous savez, ici, dans ce centre, nous formons de jeunes assistants ou assistantes.
Et clairement, au bout d'un an, ils sont formés à rechercher l'endométriose. Donc ils ont entendu nos conversations, ils ont assisté à nos consultations.
Donc si vous voulez, ça va faire boule de neige. Donc c'est l'enseignement vraiment au quotidien lors des consultations.
Donc il faut le temps que ça porte ses fruits.
OK. Donc vous êtes optimiste à ce niveau-là aussi.
Oui, oui. Oui, oui.
Ces jeunes patientes, une fois qu'on les repère, donc via prise de sang et non pas via imagerie médicale, on peut essayer de trouver un traitement hormonal, la bonne pilule qui va leur convenir.
Exact.
Pas toujours simple, mais vous disiez
Voilà
...tout un panel de pilules qu'on peut leur offrir. Et donc là, ce que j'ai du mal à comprendre, c'est quelle est la place pour la reproduction si on leur donne, si on les, entre guillemets, on les condamne à une aménorrhée.
Ça veut dire pas de bébé, a priori.
Oui, mais bon, tout ça est temporaire. Donc, c'est sûr que si vous prescrivez une pilule à quelqu'un de 14, 15 ans, si 10 ans plus tard, elle dit : « Voilà, maintenant, je souhaite
un enfant », clairement, elle va arrêter sa pilule et on verra à ce moment-là où on en est.
Mais probablement que si on a pu protéger cette patiente pendant 10 ans du reflux menstruel, probablement que même si on trouve de l'endométriose, elle sera moins grave et moins difficile à opérer, en fait.
Mh. D'accord. Et donc, est-ce que les douleurs, à ce moment-là, vont, de manière générale, revenir au moment où on arrête le traitement ?
Est-ce qu'une patiente qui est enceinte connaît encore des douleurs et des troubles ?
Vous connaissez la réponse, monsieur.
Non, je ne connais pas. Arrêtez, arrêtez de m'accuser de tout savoir. Je ne connais pas la réponse.
Donc en fait, y a un vieux dicton, qui était utilisé dans les années 50, donc quand même, nous n'étions pas nés.
Non.
Début des années 50, on va dire. Et donc, on disait à toutes ces patientes qui avaient de l'endométriose : « Madame, soyez enceinte et vous allez voir, pendant la grossesse, vous n'aurez plus mal.
» Et en fait, ceci est basé sur le fait que pendant la grossesse, les patientes ont des grosses sécrétions de progestérone.
Et comme tout à l'heure, je vous l'ai dit, l'endométriose va être calmée par la progestérone et donc les patientes ne seront plus symptomatiques.
Le seul problème, c'est que les patientes qui ont beaucoup d'endométriose, elles ne seront pas enceintes spontanément dans la majorité des cas.
Donc on tourne en rond, voilà.
En particulier au début des années 50, le fait de tomber enceinte était beaucoup plus compliqué pour les patientes qui connaissaient de l'endométriose.
Oui.
Et je pense qu'il y avait aussi peut-être une logique, une mentalité au début des années 50 vis-à-vis de : faites des bébés, faites des bébés, faites des bébés, qui était...
Tout à fait.
Voilà, le baby boom, voilà, donc toutes ces choses qui se croisent entre elles. OK. Donc cette jeune patiente qui décide d'interrompre son traitement pour tomber enceinte,
à ce moment-là, est-ce que ça se fait généralement facilement ou est-ce que...
Donc on parle d'une personne qui prend un traitement depuis très tôt, décide d'interrompre son traitement pour tomber enceinte.
Est-ce qu'à ce moment-là, ça se passe généralement bien ou est-ce que ?
Vous savez quand même qu'il existe plusieurs conditions pour obtenir une grossesse.
Oui.
Donc après 10 ans de pilule et donc de freinage de l'hypothalamus et de l'hypophyse, qui sont les glandes qui sont indispensables pour l'ovulation,
il faut d'abord que ce frein soit lâché et que donc l'activité physiologique reprenne.
Donc ça, c'est la première chose. Donc il faut d'abord voir en combien de temps la patiente va retrouver des cycles normaux.
Bien clairement, il faut trouver le partenaire qui a un spermogramme sans pathologie. Et vous savez qu'actuellement, c'est quelque chose de plus en plus difficile.
Mh.
Donc je n'ai pas de boule de cristal, mais je dirais que si toutes les conditions sont bonnes, un retour de l'ovulation rapidement avec un partenaire qui n'a pas d'antécédents ou pas de problèmes de fertilité,
si cette patiente n'a pas d'endométriose
ou très, très peu, elle pourrait être enceinte rapidement.
Mais là encore, je n'ai pas de chiffres à vous donner.
Et donc à ce moment-là, cette patiente-là va petit à petit, les années vont passer, va finir par connaître une ménopause.
Donc même là, vous disiez des possibilités de douleurs qui pourraient se maintenir même après la ménopause. Et je ne sais plus si je vous ai posé la question, qu'est-ce qu'on conseille à ce moment-là à ces patientes
ménopausées qui connaissent encore des douleurs ?
Ben, y a pas 36 solutions, hein. Donc une patiente, imaginons, qui a de l'endométriose au niveau intestinal ou au niveau vaginal, si elle garde douleur, on doit intervenir, on doit opérer, on doit réséquer la lésion d'endométriose.
J'ai l'impression que si je fais la synthèse de tout ce que vous m'avez expliqué, médicalement, ça va ou ça va de mieux en mieux, ça va vers le mieux.
Les recherches, donc, que vous attendez vis-à-vis des biomarqueurs, vous êtes plutôt positive à ce niveau-là.
Mh.
Donc finalement, ça va. Là où ça ne va pas, c'est plutôt un niveau politique, un niveau sociétal, le fait que ça reste encore très méconnu.
On continue à associer les règles à la douleur. On continue à penser que les femmes sont condamnées intrinsèquement à une douleur et que c'est inévitable, que c'est pas très grave.
Je pense que je reviens régulièrement vers ce point-là, mais qu'est-ce que--
est-ce qu'au niveau de l'éducation, voilà, l'éducation sexuelle au sens large, est-ce que vous sentez qu'on va vers le mieux ou bien est-ce que ça traîne ?
Est-ce qu'aujourd'hui, vous êtes satisfaite de là où on en est vis-à-vis de l'éducation sexuelle ?
Ben je dirais qu'il suffit de voir le nombre de demandes d'interruption volontaire de grossesse que nous observons ici à Liège pour se rendre compte que l'éducation n'est pas...
D'accord.
...n'est pas parfaite.
Alors, pour rebondir sur votre commentaire précédent concernant les politiques, je pense que ce que demandent les patientes, hein, qui sont vraiment
traitées ou opérées à répétition, c'est d'être reconnues quelque part, qu'on reconnaisse que ce soit une pathologie chronique, hein.
C'est pas quelque chose qui arrive pendant une année puis qui disparaît. Parce que finalement, des patientes qu'on réopère, on en a tous, hein.
On peut pas dire : « J'opère une fois puis c'est terminé.
» Donc reconnaître que c'est une pathologie chronique qui va vraiment impacter la vie de tous les jours, la vie de couple aussi, hein, parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de l'impact sur le couple, hein, parce que finalement,
cet impact n'est pas négligeable et y a une répercussion sur la vie de la patiente et forcément du couple en lui-même.
On arrive tout doucement vers la fin de cet entretien. Est-ce que vous avez un point que nous n'avons pas encore abordé, que vous souhaiteriez explorer pour terminer cet entretien ?
Je crois qu'on a quand même balayé beaucoup de points. Vous aviez préparé votre dossier vraiment brillamment avec connaissance des dernières données de la littérature.
Donc, je pense que bon, le message, c'est de dire : « Bon ben, il faut un diagnostic précoce. » Comment fait-on un diagnostic précoce ?
Ben, c'est l'écoute. Et puis les examens complémentaires, c'est quand même pas très compliqué. Et puis après, la prise en charge, je dirais, elle est assez classique, hein.
Proposer un traitement hormonal, proposer une chirurgie. Parce que tout à l'heure, vous disiez : « Bah, le traitement hormonal, l'aménorrhée va calmer les douleurs.
» Pas dans tous les cas, bien sûr.
Hein, donc les patientes qui ont vraiment des grosses lésions digestives ou un uretère qui est tout à fait sténosé vont avoir des répercussions sur le rein lui-même et donc le traitement hormonal ne suffira pas.
Donc il faut suivre les patientes et en tout cas leur donner quand même bon espoir et se dire que la chirurgie associée au traitement médical va les aider grandement.
Pour conclure, au vu des chiffres qu'on donnait tout à l'heure, donc 10, 15 % de femmes qui connaîtraient de l'endométriose, je pense qu'on peut dire qu'il y a très certainement aujourd'hui,
parmi nos auditrices qui nous écoutent là, maintenant, tout de suite, des femmes qui connaissent de l'endométriose sans le savoir.
Est-ce qu'on peut arriver à cette conclusion ?
Bien sûr. Quand je vois des patientes qui viennent en consultation, parfois, quand j'ai le temps, je leur demande : « Tiens, comment ça se fait que vous êtes arrivée jusqu'ici ?
» Elles disent : « Ben voilà, j'ai lu Internet, je me suis retrouvée dans les symptômes. J'ai cherché sur Internet un gynécologue liégeois » et elle arrive chez un gynécologue liégeois.
Donc les patientes aujourd'hui s'intéressent à leurs douleurs, ont accès à Internet et s'identifient aux symptômes dont on a parlé tout à l'heure.
Donc ce serait peut-être une partie de l'explication de pourquoi est-ce qu'on s'en rend beaucoup plus compte aujourd'hui.
C'est parce que finalement-
Oui.
...les patientes arrivent presque à contourner-
Tout à fait.
...le problème du gynécologue initial qui va, voilà, nier leur pathologie.
Tout à fait. Il y a les réseaux sociaux.
Oui.
Il y a l'association Endométriose. Donc les patientes passent, parlent entre elles et se disent : « Ben, j'ai les mêmes symptômes que toi, donc tu dois aussi avoir de l'endométriose.
» Donc c'est quelque chose effectivement qui fait boule de neige. Et les patientes, pour ça, sont fort actives.
Et du coup, pour ces
personnes qui nous écoutent et qui se disent : « Mais en fait, je connais ça personnellement » ou « Mais en fait, il y a dans mon entourage proche des personnes
que ça pourrait concerner », qu'est-ce que vous leur dites à ces personnes-là ?
Ben, je pense que d'abord, il faut peut-être revoir le médecin traitant et en rediscuter. Hein, je pense qu'il faut-
Insister.
Oui, c'est ça. Je pense qu'il ne faut pas se ruer sur toutes les consultations parce que bon, à un moment donné, on n'y arrivera de façon pas.
Mais au moins en discuter avec le médecin traitant et voir comment faire pour faire avancer le diagnostic, hein, parce que les médecins traitants peuvent aussi demander des examens complémentaires.
Et puis, s'ils sont convaincus ou en tout cas pensent que la patiente peut avoir de l'endométriose, bien sûr, les envoyer aux différents centres ici en Belgique.
Très bien. Michelle Nisolle, merci beaucoup.
Merci à vous. Merci.
Au revoir. C'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. J'espère qu'il vous a plu. J'espère que vous avez pu apprendre plein de choses sur l'endométriose.
Vous l'avez entendu, Michelle Nisolle a été très aimable et m'a complimenté un paquet de fois sur mon travail de préparation.
En toute honnêteté, j'étais vraiment à la bourre et j'ai rapidement acheté un livre sur le sujet que j'ai vite parcouru dans le train entre Bruxelles et Liège.
Un très bon bouquin, donc, très à jour sur ces questions et que je ne peux que vous conseiller. Ça s'appelle Endométriose : Ce que les autres pays ont à nous apprendre de Marie-Rose Galès.
C'est très complet, très pédagogique et, visiblement, ça permet de préparer une interview en dernière minute. Je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Dans les semaines qui viennent, on va parler politique belge ainsi que handicap, puisque j'aurai bientôt la chance de recevoir Alistair Houdayer et Elisa Rojas.
Pour ne rien manquer de tout ça, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner à Septante Minutes Avec sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
C'est gratuit. N'oubliez pas de peut-être laisser une note, par exemple, de cinq étoiles sur votre plateforme de podcast qui permet ça.
Et n'oubliez pas de nous suivre sur les réseaux sociaux, comme par exemple Twitter, Facebook ou ma page perso sur Instagram.
Prenez soin de vous. À très bientôt.